So we've seen we can create derive classes and they inherit attributes from
their base class. We can create another derive class. We'll make a BlackBear and
we can add attributes to our derived classes. So we'll give the BlackBear a
climb_tree method and a chase method. Here's what the BlackBear code looks like.
It's base class is Bear. It's got two additional methods to find, the climb_tree
method and the chase method. And in the chase method, we'll use climb_tree. We
also use eat. Since BlackBear doesn't define eat, it will inherit the eat method
from the base class, and we'll be using the bear's eat method. Yummy, yummy,
yummy. So let's see how that works. We create our human victim Dave, and we'll
put him up the tree, then we create a BlackBear. Then we have Yogi chase our
victim. We see that Yogi can climb the tree and eat the victim. If we create a
GrizzlyBear and have the GrizzlyBear try to chase Dave, well, we have not
defined the chase attribute for the GrizzlyBear. And it doesn't inherit it from
BlackBear since its base class is Bear, it's not a subclass of BlackBear.